tan
car
then
it's time to
start 4 a my la
[music]
is there any injury?
It's
fine because it's
grandma's will.
I
'm sorry Izzet sympathy
Seirin rbm But yes, we're federal military Don't let your guard down Yes
It
's because of the city, so I'm going to the dam I
'm going to
the destination this time
.
Bryce sympathizes with
dz 0, but there is poetry, but
the polite Mr. Song made it to the United Nations
.
I
'm going to buy
you a federal knight apprentice
card
Right now I'm getting a pass over there I
'm fine with the amount I buy and bring I
don't mind
because
wait  Can you
please give me my medicine bag just in case, if
something happens, feel
free to use it.
It
's my duty to think for myself, I
should have taught
you that
.
But
now I'm coming to that person.
[Music] When the
hourglass fell, I came to pick it up.
It's always been that way since I was a kid,
right?
This is a service
ua Thank you
Eat a lot
I guess there was a sound quality month in such a land, wasn't it?
Music] It's
all thanks to that pillar It
wasn't built when this city was still an imperial territory It was
n't built to provide plenty of manners
That's why there was a lot of Japan
Yes,
this city used a reactor  The royal family
has unlimited fruits and vegetables, and
medical care is available in high-standard facilities.
It's a good time
Let's go get some medicine
[music]
me
[music] My
head is
alarming
I'm going to prison It's
okay
[music]
[applause]
Situation
A crowd of Bill's sitting in the seat
Lying
club  I can't grasp the distance
Let's enter the wave No,
if the gates are closed, the city will be safe with the small spearmanship.
And Blaze
's Elialdia I'm the reason why I'm the eye
That
's what
I
call the Yatsushiro frontline, and
I'm going to put a down and burn my stance I'm none Uuuu no Kuni 130er Yeah yeah yeah I'm telling you,
just be a little more today
Haa
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Music]
Kishimen
[music]
[music
] Say haha
goo yeah It's
not sweet, full card
Local officer
Dagger
Well done
Yes
Whoa
Parley
th
I
was driving the reactor
Total amount 3
Thank you pm 2 Yeah
Dawn
Bello
I guess
[Applause] You
had a hard time yesterday
but Nîmes is about to start
.
ey It's gone from the country, but is
it really that
bad?
After I made that pillar, the
mana balance collapsed, and the plants and trees lost their homes,
and we couldn't harvest any crops. We
absolutely have to stop that.
My name is Nicola
[Music]
Mr. Nicola's public area became a wasteland two years ago
lune The area around lune is
not habitable
[Music]
Then why was it abandoned until now?
You
can't do brute force destruction and you can't
stop it because
we couldn't keep up with the empire's technology
.
If you plug it into the control device on the top floor,
you can stop the mana from the pillars.
Why
is it that it was
originally owned by the empire,
so why not make
it again?
That's why this town has
n't been taken over.
At the same time, we got
information that Tenneko is coming to take back the control money. Sumo sold
a fight for control of the killer
.
It's
a good feeling
tan yeah yeah tar
Sho Ueno Did you draw it from the scalp
Teikoku White Wolf Shark
9 Soundtrack
Hirokawa
[music]
It's been a while, Leo
cell 4
I'm confused now I'm
your judge
[music]
What are you going to do with the pillars
?
Ah ah ah
Yes
[Music]
Shirogane's selection name is not Date
Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahhahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha…
Pop
I can tell you it's okay
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh
MUSIC]
I'll protect the people I care about
It
's my justice Yeah
Can I really fight? The
instructor asks me to continue to be vigilant
[MUSIC] I can
still fight after this
I
can do it
I'm from the
empire  I'm clumsy
[music]
Are you worried about me a little more?
[Music]
That's the only way
b 1 a 4
Yeah
yeah yeah Look for Fabie
[Music]
Whoa
!
After all, the glans seems to be the biggest obstacle.
Hide From
here
, let's go by the side.. I've
summarized it.The
leader's petition will make a house joint.
Tan As the
instructor said
[Music]
Empathy
?
I can understand
your hesitation ah ah ah ah you're right there is no hesitation in Tokyo
my definition is this 3 o'clock a
[music]
pandan
goo
[music]
hey
me
[music]
dec 4
car
me
British catch
[Music]
Standing for
5 minutes
Something's happening
voodoo
[Music] What's the
real purpose?
To get it
back
[music]
5 a
This
is what the cows
are aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa!!!